buongiorno a tutti allora partiamo
subito serie tv il genere poliziesco
per quanto riguarda le serie il massimo
esempio di resilienza nella storia delle
serie tv il primo esempio di poliziesco
e dragnet americano che riprende un po
uno stile della seconda metà degli anni
quaranta dove si facevano film in cui si
tentava di restituire un tono
documentaristico alle indagini che
venivano proposte spesso e volentieri
venivano proposti anche proprio casi
veri che venivano filmati come se
fossero un documentario driver net
proponeva un immagine molto elogiativa
delle forze dell'ordine negli anni 70
che una dell'epoca d'oro del poliziesco
abbiamo un piccolo una piccola mutazione
come una serie che si chiama sulle
strade della california scritta da
joseph barban bob creata da un autore di
non fiction novel immaginate gomorra e
avrete idea di che tipo di romanzi e
saggi si trattava in questa casa abbiamo
un'immagine estremamente variegata delle
forze dell'ordine quindi non più solo
positività ma anche tutto il retroscena
anche crudele che c'è dietro le immagini
delle indagini della polizia
abbiamo sempre negli anni 70 un altro
modello che il modello cool si affermano
divistici con attori divistici come il
caso di star schiacci negli anni 80 e
poliziesco si apre a due filoni che
risalgono agli anni 70 il primo è quello
di hill street giorno e notte ideato da
stephen bosco che riprende il modello
del docu fiction però adattandolo a in
maniera nuova insomma si parla di police
drama e poi abbiamo
una serie parallela che è lei la che
invece si occupa di ciò che avviene
all'interno del circuito della giustizia
parallelamente abbiamo un modello ma
ieri vice che rielabora quello di star
schiacci ovviamente in maniera più
evoluta negli anni novanta abbiamo vita
di strada e visioni patinate perché il
modello di bosco rivive in order che è
una delle serie più resilienti della
storia della televisione abbiamo oltre
venti stagioni e abbiamo una decina di
spin off e poi sempre bocci con l'autore
dirsi giorno e notte che fa york police
department
mp di blu
contemporaneamente david simon altro
scrittore di non fiction novel ricava
dalla sua visione di baltimora due serie
tv estremamente seminari uno è un inside
tratto da un suo romanzo fu romanzo non
fiction e poi the wire che è una delle
serie di culto del poliziesco degli
ultimi 15 anni
negli anni dieci del xxi secolo il
modello prevalente è quello di csi scena
del crimine il pubblico americano si
appassiona al processo di oggi i simpson
incomincia ad apprendere cose tipo
l'analisi del dna e quindi il modello
csi incomincia a diventare prevalente e
per una decina d'anni si impone però
verso la fine del decennio abbiamo un
ritorno all'umanesimo laddove si e
sawyer estremamente tecnologico
abbiamo figure come quella di lie to me
il dottore di lie to me out mentali dove
la tecnologia lascia un'altra volta
spazio alla riduzione il ritorno
definitivo avviene dapprima con su
detective che una serie di culto
letteralmente degli ultimi 23 anni
dove la visione psicologica quasi
sovrasta
l'indagine e poi abbiamo gx e american
crime che addirittura recupera lo
spirito iniziale del del documentario
che diventa fiction sono le ultime
alessio estremamente realistiche che
tendono a restituire appunto la
dimensione documentaristica della
dell'indagine per quanto riguarda la
sitcom abbiamo la residenza della risata
sarebbe interessante andare a vedere
come un modello degli anni 80 come tre
cuori in affitto si ripercuote sul new
girl che una sit com modernissima france
tracima in aver chiamato 8 bastano o la
famiglia bradford diventa modern family
con una famiglia allargata estremamente
complessa genitori blue jeans sarebbe il
caso di fare un paragone con transparent
dove addirittura abbiamo una famiglia
dove ci sono addirittura cambi di sesso
oppure omosessualità accederà con valori
quindi completamente differenti da
quello di genitori blue chips altro
modello è quello di meritalia ruscio
donne di new york incardina che hanno
problemi sentimentali chi vi ricorda
ovviamente sex and city che a sua volta
passa a
un'altra serie che le casalinghe
disperate desperate housewives altro
modello è quello di seinfield negli anni
90 che si trasforma una serie molto
cruda crudele che si trasforma in the
big bang theory altra serie molto cruda
addirittura priva di empatia nei
confronti dei personaggi
per quanto riguarda la fantascienza
ovviamente il modello resiliente
principale e star trek inutile dirmelo e
abbiamo dei modelli permanenti comunque
sono quelle di ai confini della realtà è
una serie molto poco nota in italia che
da wired i vips il modello star trek si
integra con un modello star wars e dà
vita a battlestar galattica che conosce
due visioni una degli anni 80 quella
diciamo classica e poi diventa una delle
serie di fantascienza più importanti del
dell'ultimo decennio che praticamente ha
riscosso tantissimo successo a sua volta
il modello star trek dà vita a babylon
five ea tutto l'ambaradan di stargate
con le sue dozzine di stagioni e dozzine
di spin off
il modello dopo alle zone invece si
ripercuote sotto in peak e su hicks
files sull'host e soffritti c che vi
prende quel tipo di divisione del mondo
estremamente surreale e grottesca i
modelli del xxi secolo
sono 24 una spy story estremamente forte
dove il tempo reale la cosa diventa
fondamentale che dà vita a tutta una
serie di nuovi titoli che sono prison
break strike back homeland e personalità
rest
il modello 24 incomincia a
ha incominciato a dar vita a questa
serie adrenalitica adrenaliniche cui il
poliziesco la spy story l'intrigo
diventano dominanti i soprano una
persona estremamente diciamo
apparentemente familiare che diventa un
criminale che invece un criminale the
shield dexter sono tutte figlie di del
soprano così come breaking bad
l'evoluzione del soprano e a sua volta
altri personaggi così come tony soprano
sono il protagonista di porto walk
empire lucky thompson è il protagonista
di mad men che a loro volta danno vita
ad una cosa che si chiama il però and
drama cela la dire la residenza del
tempo attraverso la fiction sono delle
serie televisive con una ricostruzione
che del tempo passato talmente perfetta
da fare immaginare addirittura che se si
potesse attraversare lo schermo
televisivo noi ci troveremmo o
nell'acqua esterna nel west della
seconda metà dell'ottocento oppure nella
new york dell'inizio del novecento di
american sa anni 80
spy story degli anni ottanta
ricostruzione perfetta degli anni 80 ho
recentemente health inc acciaio che una
serie televisiva che parla di come si è
evoluto il sistema dei dei computer
abbiamo però anche dei falsi residenti
l'uomo da sei milioni di dollari un cult
degli anni 70 mai più rivisto in tv
l'unica cosa resiliente dell'uno da 6
milioni di dollari probabilmente che il
prezzo non è aumentato
la donna bionica che a cui è stato
diciamo dedicato una fede un tentativo
di ripresa nel degli anni 2000 che è
stato non è stato graziato dal successo
la piccola casa nella prateria la stanno
rifacendo ultimamente sulle tre i valori
della grande america la religione
eccetera
nessuno però sa che l'ultima puntata di
quella casa nella prateria si conclude
con la completa distruzione di mammut
group tutto salta quindi praticamente
quasi una cosa simbolica come se quei
valori che erano stati tramandati si
fossero azzerati e alla fine happy days
che addirittura dopo il grande successo
degli anni 70 si conclude con maniere
ignominiosa mostrandoci fonzie che tenta
di saltare uno squalo mettendosi su
degli sci d'acqua un punto talmente
basso delle serie televisive che
addirittura oggi la il termine jump
shark viene utilizzato per indicare una
serie televisiva o un qualcosa che ormai
ha raggiunto il suo limite non può
andare oltre perché ormai è
completamente azzerato il concept così
io vi lascio augurandovi di non saltare
mai allo squalo
grazie a tutti